this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by original grain
use code congrats at originalgrain.com
to get 30 off the most fashionable
watches made from reclaimed whiskey
barrels beer barrels exotic woods and
even taylor guitars what yeah dude i
said it taylor guitars you're guaranteed
to find something that fits your style
and if you don't you're not fashionable
okay
they make the perfect gift as well so
whoopsie daisy original grain
plants a tree for every watch they sell
so also you can be a good person
purchase it up
if you don't like it they'll buy it back
from you
okay so this is a win-win-win you ever
heard of a win-win-win
the thing i like actually are these
sunglasses because you know me mmm
future's too bright but also check it
out also dude the rings
you know your boy's getting married so
the ring dude
popping um
yeah so uh they make wedding rings
sunglasses apple watch bands made from
the same sustainably sourced materials
make sure you use code congrats for 30
off
originalgrain.com to support this
podcast speaking of which
on with the episode
[Music]
crazy
so that's what's up baby uh let's keep
this song this
is nice you know what i mean
kind of killing it we're keeping it real
dude but also future's too bright so
we're keeping it real uh yeah dude
another episode of congratulations uh in
the books dude right now i mean you're
not for you you didn't listen to it yet
but for me because it's through it's i'm
through with it i'm through with it if
you're listening to it i already did the
episode that's how time works but uh
yeah and that's what's up
i had a good i've been you know things
have been cool i've been doing shows and
all that i got a show coming up in
arizona phoenix arizona crystalia.com go
to phoenix arizona go to chrisley.com go
to uh the phoenix area i'm gonna be in
phoenix arizona at the celebrity theater
you can click on the link crystallia.com
phoenix some common don't push me and
then irvine we added a show uh a late
show on thursday because your boy just
keeps filling emceed so
chrisley.com uh we're adding new new
dates and all that stuff soon actually
it may be up here by the time this gets
up there no that probably won't but
phoenix go see your boy chrisley.com
anyway um
merch don't push me oops grenade
chrisleya.com it's all part of the
process dude and you know me i'm just
keeping it alive keeping it moving um
i'm having a good time in life i uh
i went to go
well i was getting ready for bed the
other day uh with kristen and every now
and then she tries to bully me into
going to sleep with her at like 10 30
but i don't want to because you know i
stay up late i do stuff like i watch
[ __ ] tv shows like i'll watch just
crazy like well i'll watch that thing on
boeing that's on netflix that thing on
boeing i don't even know if it's on
netflix or not but um
i started watching it boeing made the
same mistake twice nine months apart and
killed like 300 people and they're still
a company
so it's like and why are they still a
company because bags yeah but everyone
died but also bags got to keep it real
though it's bags that kept the company
alive and also bags that killed those
people just i don't mean to start on a
shower note but it's true bags are the
best and worst of us
and uh so bags can help you get from
place to place but also not everyone
cause some people die because of bags
but i'm keeping it real and i don't mean
to keep it so real and be so harsh right
off the bat but that's the truth anyway
dude what are we gonna do not take
boeing isn't it the only one that makes
airplanes unless you're on a cessna
unless you want to travel like the
jetsons with that
[Applause]
i do that to get the food in my son's
mouth but anyway so i'm watching that
and you know i like to stay up late at
night and i'm also trying to watch the
thing about pam
and it's terrible yes of course but i
like renee zellweger
so i'm trying to watch out i'm also
trying to watch the [ __ ] crazy
documentary with uh what's his name not
son of sam what's the other one john
wayne gacy who i always thought was the
creepiest serial killer uh because of
that clown picture imagine that foot
that photographer taken by the way he
hired somebody to take that
to do a
photo uh a photo shoot with the clown
outfit on
he hired someone john mcgacy liked to hi
like to
dress up as a clown and do clown makeup
he said you know a lot of people unwind
with like whiskey and drugs and pot not
me i like to dress up in clown makeup
and that's what he said that he likes to
do ton wine that's more serial killer
than killing a bunch of people that's
more serial killer than serial killing
unwinding with clown makeup on
and he never even admitted that he did
it he's just like well that's what i got
convicted for but anyway dude so that's
what i like to do i like to stay up i
like to watch stuff like on john wayne
gay say i like to stay up and watch
stuff about plane crash and then also
you know lots of murder [ __ ] late at
night i watch right even if it's 2020 or
dateline or whatever but i let you wah i
watch a lot of murder [ __ ]
and chris is always like i'm going to
bed because she's like a [ __ ] you
know she's in her she's in her school
teacher vibes right because she's like
trying to go to bed at like 10 o'clock
so she could wake up early with you know
and be a good mom and [ __ ] which i
respected and i love it and she's a
great mommy and that's awesome dude but
also like you're not going to drag your
boy into school teacher territory
you're not you're not you're not going
to drag [ __ ] johnny stays up later
than you into [ __ ] schoolteacher
schedule mode you know that's not my
[ __ ] dude my [ __ ] is johnny stays up
later than you right
so while i'm staying up later than you
dude i'm on my vampire [ __ ] she's like
can we go to bed and find so i you know
i give in do it because you don't want
to argue and so i give in and not that
we're gonna argue but i give in right so
i gave in once and i went to go to sleep
and all of a sudden
i walk up to my side of the bed and i go
over to it and i'm like oh [ __ ] there's
like a what the [ __ ] like there's a
banana peel on the side of the bed
like just i guess cow was eating a
banana or something just you know how
you take i don't know if you've ever
seen like a banana peel like 30 minutes
after
you're done with it if you leave it out
it's like i don't know how
it it dies so quickly like it's so
[ __ ] decayed brown like we have so
many bananas because cal wakes up and he
says
and so we give him a banana and he eats
habit puts it down and then all of a
sudden there's like this brown [ __ ]
decayed banana peel and i'm like this is
so gross and we throw it away so
there what is
right there's a decayed brown banana
peel next to my bed now who knows how
long it's been there because it's
nighttime right it's night time and the
bananas are only eaten
on the first part of the day so this
decay banana peel has been there for a
long time
because banana peels become brown you
know the whole saying banana peels come
become brown after 30 minutes they after
30 minutes
that's a saying
and so i go to say i say oh babe what
the [ __ ] man
you gave banana you gave you gave calvin
a banana peel you've gave calvin a
banana and you left the banana peel out
here and i go down to grab it
and i go to pick it up and it's stuck to
the carpet because it's gross because
the banana is sticking to the carpet and
then i go down to grab it again
and then kristen says hey don't do that
honey that's [ __ ]
it was [ __ ]
it wasn't a banana peel
it was clumps of [ __ ]
i was trying to pick up [ __ ] with no
gloves i was trying to pick up [ __ ] with
no [ __ ] pooper scooper i was just
picking up [ __ ] like it was some m m's
oh it was gross dude my worst part was
kristen watched me do the whole [ __ ]
thing from jump she saw me try to pick
it up one time and then try to pick it
up again and then after that was the
time she decided to say hey honey don't
pick that up it's [ __ ]
what about the first time
yant your hubby touching [ __ ]
got a quick question for you fiance
yacht your hubby touch and [ __ ]
all good if you do but please admit it
right now for the courtroom
you're a hubby touching [ __ ]
so now i'm shitty hands i'm the new dick
tracy villain shitty hands and i'm
[ __ ] pissed and then i say what the
[ __ ] is [ __ ] and she says you thought it
was a banana peel
and now i look like a [ __ ] [ __ ] i
look like an [ __ ] because we didn't
have the conversation about how banana
peels look all brown in like five
minutes so now i'm like god damn it i
got [ __ ] on my hands and i walk into the
[ __ ] bathroom to wash my hands
naturally and she says ew you just go to
pick it up without investigating it and
i said i thought it was a banana peel
and she said it was way too small to be
a banana peel and you know what god
dammit is right but i thought she picked
up some of it and left the other one
that was left to other pieces that were
dirty because she didn't get all of it
because she didn't care but
so then i go to wash my hands i get the
toilet paper and i'm like i gotta clean
this [ __ ] up why i said why didn't so
you knew [ __ ] was here
and she was like i don't know and i was
like well no if you knew she was here
why didn't you clean it up
and she said the most honest thing that
anyone has ever said in the history of
honest things
she said well
i kind of noticed it a while ago
but then tried to put it out of my brain
because i didn't want to have to pick it
up
ah
i noticed it earlier but kind of was
pretending i didn't because i didn't
want to admit to myself that's what you
said i didn't want to admit to myself
that there was [ __ ] on the floor
uh
so now
i gotta ask you that's fine but
you got your hubby to have [ __ ] on his
hands
dude
so now i'm all pissed and now i'm
cleaning it i grabbed toilet paper she's
like what are you doing i'm like well i
got to clean the [ __ ] [ __ ] off the
thing and then i noticed like there's
splotches of it on the rug
like and just like sam or butters or
chenzo was just dotting it they were
just putting their anus down on the rug
and they weren't even doing the dragon
thing they were just like
walking a little bit and then just
sitting dot in the rug with some [ __ ]
just walking a little bit further just
dotting the [ __ ] rug with some [ __ ]
like they were like they were like
worried that they were never gonna find
their way back
butters and sam just ah you know all you
have to do is follow the [ __ ] dots
yeah yeah
or just actually go to [ __ ]
is yelling so chris is yelling about
[ __ ] having [ __ ] in his hands just
follow the screams
so that's what happened so i had [ __ ]
all over my hands and i had to wash it
and then i'm completely up and i'm like
you wanted me to go go to bed like a
[ __ ] school teacher there's no way in
hell now i'm all [ __ ] heated with
[ __ ] on my hands
so
anyway
the [ __ ] dots are still there by the way
i don't know i want to use like [ __ ]
reshuvenator or something to clean it up
or johnny marks whatever i use for my
shoes but she won't even [ __ ] i don't
even know if they're clean and the
cleaners are gonna come by and they're
just gonna be like that's not that's not
for us that's not we don't do that we
just tidy we tidy we don't scrape [ __ ]
off drugs
so i know that that's gonna happen so
whatever dude it's fine you know it's
like you live and you learn and also
you got to keep moving
you got to keep moving no matter how
much shit's on your hand you got to keep
moving you got to keep moving
um
yeah watch this bad vegan thing this
show bad vegan um on uh is it on netflix
yeah it was like people are like if you
like the tinder swindler you'll love bad
vegan and it's like well i didn't really
like this tinder swindler everyone it's
one of those things dude and maybe i'm i
don't i'm not a hater dude but like okay
tinder swindler like dude all right so
also and i made this thing where it was
like you know you could google it i i
talked about it on one of the other
pocket one of the other episodes but
it's like yeah also the tinder swindled
you but also don't give someone twenty
thousand dollars after you give them
eighty thousand dollars that's the
golden rule you know the golden rule
where they're like do unto others as
others do what you want to be done to
you by the way i don't believe in that
rule i don't believe in the golden rule
right what's the golden rule do unto
others as you want to be done to
yourself or whether the [ __ ] that it
trails off i don't know but honestly
that rule is [ __ ] because how do i
know how you want to be treated oh i'm
so egotistical that i'm going to treat
you how i want to be treated some people
like to get spit on like gets dude
there's videos out there i was on the
port i was deep in porn the other day
and there was a dude just sitting there
with his arms behind his back and some
lady smoking a cigarette and [ __ ]
booting his nuts and anus
oh excuse me that's not for me in case
you come across me and you want to do
the golden rule on me but you like
getting [ __ ] booted to the nuts and
anus i'm okay with that
you understand
the golden
rule could go [ __ ] itself dude how about
this is the golden rule do one to me
as you know about my history and you
think i want to be done to
okay
dude there's [ __ ] out there
that like you know
want their fingers down their throats
and [ __ ] it's like they're kink it ain't
mine
don't boot my nuts just cause you like
it you ever heard of the pain olympics
no i'm not into it
so now the golden rule is [ __ ] you
know don't give someone twenty thousand
dollars after you give them eighty
thousand dollars especially with all
these [ __ ] things so they're like if
you like with these documentaries out
now they're making so many documentaries
documentaries that jump to shark
it's like if you like the tinder
swindler alright fine but what about
nobody's responsible for this [ __ ]
yeah this guy's a piece of [ __ ] but
nobody's responsible you're just forking
over money like
because quote-unquote people are after
them dude imagine someone comes up to
you even a friend even a friend and then
like someone's after me give me 25k
what the [ __ ] do you think you would say
to your friend and by the way twisted
what the [ __ ] do you think your friend
would say to you
[ __ ] no dude
start a gofundme
so i'm watching bad vegan because
someone's like if you like tinder it's
always the second one that comes out
that everyone pretends to like more
because everyone loved the first one and
they're like they want to be a little
bit different about it right
you know what i'm talking about it's
like the same same energy as the people
who are like oh yeah well i was the one
i actually knew that band way before
their album came out same energy dude
same [ __ ] energy dude you know when i
like the bands after everyone knows them
and i ain't ashamed of [ __ ] dude i just
found out about coldplay
okay
so um
so anyway
like i'm watching the bad vegan and i'm
watching this thing and i'm like yeah
this guy's like being a piece of [ __ ]
and trying to like get money from this
chick and they're interviewing this
chick
who's like this vegan
has this pure luck pure food [ __ ]
daily whatever the hell it's called i
don't know
vegan places always have the worst
[ __ ] names it's either like it's
either like real food raw organic
or like
golden lucky pot
and it's like just
you know
can it just be like frank's
frank's food frank's frank's it's just
it's always like some cute [ __ ] or like
some pa the most basic [ __ ]
so i'm getting uh so i'm watching bad
vegan and this woman is like it's what
is it like four episodes five episodes
this woman who owns the place who got
swindled right
the vegan swindler she got swindled from
this guy that was like
like he was a lunatic he had mental
problems but like you know just covered
it with charisma and charm i guess and
he was like i'm gonna need some money
because there are some there's this like
there's this whatever i don't even know
what you would call it a faction out
there or there's these people that
decide on who gets to uh
be
babel you know what i don't even know
how he put it but he ended up saying
like if you want your dog to live
forever and be immortal you gotta keep
giving me money so i can put it in a
place and you gotta follow my rules so
your dog can be immortal and she just
says
kay
you know
she's just like okay this is the first
episode she's like well i wanted my dog
to be immortal so and it didn't like go
and then go like
it didn't even nothing happened except
they were just documenting her saying
this and she's like yeah i want to he
made me think my dog was going to be
immortal and he psychologically abused
me
and i'm just like okay i'm waiting for
the documentary to be like
hey say it's her fault though
right
we can all agree right
because if someone's like
give me 80 000 and you're like no
and then they're like okay but don't you
want your dog to be immortal and then
you're like you're the first thing you
don't say think is oh thanks for
confirming you're a lunatic
and you just say okay here's the money
that's on you
right
and now we're making documentaries not
just about [ __ ] psychological
abusers but hey how about
documentaries now have jumped the shark
because we're making documentaries about
gullible [ __ ]
hey man
this is like
and everyone's like this [ __ ]
everyone's like this [ __ ]
psychologically no this documentary is
about a gollum match
this documentary is about a woman that
met a guy that was ah
sad
and sought to lunch that she thought she
could pay a hundred grand actually
1.5 million was the total sum at the end
of it
to keep her dog
from the afterlife
thinking
oops we made a mistake as humanity right
so don't be doing that okay so i'm done
with these documentaries these
psychological abusers that [ __ ] by
the way where's your responsibility huh
where do you come into play huh
i'm done with the gullible
documentary i'm done with it yeah i
didn't know i had no idea
oh you didn't have an idea
when he said fly to rome and await
further instructions
and you stayed there for months on end
calling him why am i here and he said i
can't tell you
that wasn't your sign
like you're some [ __ ] like
you know
have you even held a dossier
you own a [ __ ] vegan place
you're not a spy who are you [ __ ]
ethan
hunt
this isn't mission impossible by the way
they made nine okay it's not really that
impossible anymore he gets it done
should just be called missions
but dude i mean i'm done with gullible
[ __ ] documentaries
i'm just done with it dude
i never knew you didn't know
come on dude you knew
they're not all ted bundy that guy was
handsome as [ __ ] smiling looking in your
eyes every other serial killer looks
like [ __ ] the the the the guy in uh
napoleon dynamite
the [ __ ] skinny one with the mustache
every other serial killer looks like
that you didn't know they're not all ted
bundy look at john wayne casey dressed
up in a clown and did photo shoots they
should have locked them up that day
that that's against the law that should
be against the law yeah well no but it's
like 98 of the time it's true they are
[ __ ] actual
they do [ __ ] kill young boys if
that's what they do for leisure they
said he'd like to unwind by putting on
by putting on [ __ ] clown makeup so
you know he obviously murdered more than
30 boys let's check his let's check his
crawl spaces
come on
dude the [ __ ] the the the ego on john
wayne gacy unbelievable that you should
lock anybody up who uses three names
anyway john wayne gacy like get the [ __ ]
out
that's so cocksucky and also
they he would they were tailing him
because they didn't there was like
mystery around him and dude he would
walk out to the cops across the street
and he'd be like are you guys cops and
they'd be like well we're just doing
what we're told to and he'd be like why
don't you come in for dinner dude he'd
bring him in to dinner and then and then
the cops like smelled death when he
turned on the heat because there were
bodies underground near the [ __ ]
heater and that was how they got their
warrant their search warrant and then
they found 33
17 year old boys bones in his [ __ ]
crawl space the ego on serial killers
dude
they think they know they think they
know you know that the cops aren't going
to find the [ __ ] out unbelievable
so anyway bad vegan they should they
should [ __ ] change that documentary
to gullible [ __ ] and also dude the
[ __ ] chick is like i'm out of here i
thought you know social media is so
toxic it's like yeah dude
dogs can't be immortal
and there's our episode title
but decant though dude
you ever try to stab his dog all over
again over and over again they die i
didn't i never done it but i'm pretty
sure
this is the most gangster [ __ ] dude
finally a company that doesn't give a
[ __ ] for real dude and we should have
known all along it was going to be
arby's we should have known all along
that that [ __ ] was gonna be arby's dude
you know why because arby's is gangster
do you know why
because arby's
uh is so
um
like who goes to arby's
right have you have you met by the way
have you ever met somebody that went to
arby's if you have
then
you know
you're so
if if you know some like it it's like
this the people who go to arby's
now
for sure midwestern is [ __ ] right even
if the arby's are in l.a like if you
know somebody that is
that has been to an arby's you are from
the midwest if you know someone who
knows someone that is from arby's you
might not be from the midwest like 80
chance and then if you know someone who
you know someone who you know someone
who went to arby's like 60 and keep
dropping and dropping and dropping it's
like the six degrees of kevin bacon it's
like six degrees of arby's right um
so they had to do something they had to
get out of that [ __ ] bubble dude
because mcdonald's is worldwide right
burger king that be worldwide taco bell
be worldwide arby's might be worldwide
but it's not really in the lexicon right
when you mention fast food you don't
think of arby's well they changed all
that finally somebody did a [ __ ]
gangster [ __ ] they took pusha t who used
to do [ __ ] for mcdonald's and made a
diss track on a commercial for arby's
against mcdonald's can i even play it i
don't know we maybe if it flags us put
this on the patreon
i'm the reason the whole world love it
now i gotta crush it fellaio fishes [ __ ]
then you should be disgusted how dare
you sell a square fish asking us to
trust it a half slice of cheese mickey
d's on a budget yeah are these crispy
fishes and it's good dude with lines
we might need a guest list eggs left the
sandwiches taste right listen to this
song and get dome guys clown is basic
stateless yeah this argument is baseless
drowned in tartar that filet o fish is
tasty nice see arby's only deals in the
greatness i bet the house on it like
it's vegas
yeah the crispy fish sandwich blazing
trails the mother clown's just too
friendly this is the best part right
here yeah if you know me and you know me
well all fish is gonna tip that skin he
put in a coke reference
he put in a oh he put in a coke
reference
he put in a [ __ ] coke reference
he put in a [ __ ] reference about
cocaine on a [ __ ] worldwide
mainstream commercial
pusha t that's why he's go they call him
pusha cause he pushes the limit
dude oh he pushed the [ __ ] coke
reference into a goddamn 30-second rb
spot they're gonna run on tv
dude and that's what you need to do
now i've been saying this [ __ ] companies
needs to grab some nuts but they [ __ ]
nutted up didn't they arby's nodded it
up
arby's [ __ ] straight up grabbed their
nuts
and just looked at these [ __ ]
corporate [ __ ] and was like you know
what [ __ ] it dude let's make a diss
track whoever and i'm telling you now
all of a sudden arby's is in the
conversation
dude arby's wasn't in the conversation
before this dropped and now it is and
it's just like
we wanted it all along
this is what we wanted from corporate
america all along now
don't get mistaken they're still just
trying to sell sauce and their own fish
biscuits but still though
this is a move towards greatness and
when arby's wanted to be in the
discussion i just simply go like this
he worked a coke reference into a
mainstream commercial
so pusha t is the killer dude pusha t is
the mcdonald's killer didn't he come up
with like [ __ ] bada papaya or some
[ __ ] he came up with some jingle for
mcdonald's and they didn't pay him so he
made a diss track for the other comp for
the by the way they weren't even the
competitor but now they are mcdonald's
answer get bun b on the track dude
answer
pay jay z pay [ __ ] drake pay
him
[ __ ] that i'll go in and eat all arby's
now
i'm gonna eat all the [ __ ] arby's i
wonder if i can play that commercial on
the [ __ ] you think i can
dude i need to [ __ ] eat all the
arby's that's so dope that they did that
and he worked a coke reference in it
just next one should just be you know me
snorting up all the coke at arby's
the boom
and she had my coke
[Music]
took my dick out and started pissing all
over
i'm with alex jones and we [ __ ] hate
we hate everyone that's not us
the vaccine is fake it doesn't work at
all
[Music]
dude are you kidding me
hell yeah dude
[ __ ] yeah dude this is the [ __ ] that
needs to happen
i'm telling you it's on its way anyway
you can push it you you can or you can
try to make pretend like it's not gonna
push like you could go ahead and you
could keep making your [ __ ] stupid
charming commercials with the purple
bear
or you can act like these [ __ ]
are coming for your head
and one's true and one's not
mike tyson made gummy ears
okay because he beat evander how the
[ __ ] you think evan holyfield feels
about that probably pretty bad
if he even understands that it's
happening because he's been boxed to the
[ __ ] head his whole life and shakes a
lot
but mike tyson was like yeah i his ear
let's put out gummy cbd ears okay
so you can act like the shit's not
coming but it's coming i'm telling you
in [ __ ] five to ten years there's
going to be a commercial where somebody
[ __ ] literally stabbed someone
or like you know
i don't know how do you oh no there's a
[ __ ] peeping tom and he's jerking off
in my window what the [ __ ] and it's
gonna be like
an adt commercial
adt we're here for you
if guys be jerking off outside in your
plant
we're here for you
boom boom boom enough with the guys
outside jerking off boom boom boom
alex jones is the [ __ ]
um
so anyway
it's like you you can hurt
people you there's
you got it
it's only nice if you can hurt people's
feelings man i hate to say it but that's
where the bags that's where the most
bags are
the second you play it safe and play it
too calm i was i saw a flyer the other
day and it said like what the [ __ ] was
it it was like uh
for
uh safe comedy during these hard times
and it was just like huh
but comedy
huh
but hold on someone wants a word let him
in
hi guys who are you i'm comedy
can i join
not on this show
this plano texas
[ __ ] dude
right
god this guy let me pull it up
plano texas
now the greatest rapper from plano texas
is a [ __ ]
this clip
first of all
i'm the proof when i'm in the booth
spitting on the mic it's anti-vaxx putin
hates all of them blacks who den is a
bad racist
put them in the ground white or brown
and i'm in plain old town and you know
you just got found
i'm a pimp on a blimp
[Music]
and shrimp
oh
god you know first of all so out of
breath immediately
dude
i'm a pimp on a blimp you know no you
just got found
i'm a pimp on a blimp the worst
[ __ ] rap of all time i'm a pimp on a
blimp
sounds like two chains um
no you can't stop my son i'm number man
and you know i'm
this is a city council meeting guys
whoops forgot to say that
this is a city council meeting and he's
just dressed like somebody at a city
council and he's white as [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
the most violent thing i ever said is a
city council meeting put a bullet in
putin's brain you know that is the plan
i'm a zelinski stan
i love you vladimir zelinski you are so
what can you say
fascinate me straight again
i love you and i love to rhyme and grind
all the time
and you got that sanitizer
and you know i got that visor
[Music]
put a bullet in poutine
[Music]
dude
wow
how much is this guy gonna die in five
years and then we're gonna be like
remember that guy oh [ __ ] that was that
guy
you know the flow
and i am a pimp not a pimp
[Music]
[Music]
oh he's taking his shirt off now his
blazer take my picture i'm a winner i'm
gonna eat you for dinner okay you want
to go to us i just want to say
i love you we need to take out vladimir
putin like lindsey graham said thank you
mayor muns i appreciate the time peace
god bless you all
primetime stein on instagram thank you
oh we got you down we got you down
one gut person
[Applause]
oh wow
oh brian
um
dude this is unreal dude i'm a pimp on a
plan you know so bad dude
oh my god
wow well he's famous now and now
i you know what oh god how annoying is
that guy probably
i don't even know what to say about a
guy like that honestly i was like oh
this will be good for the podcast and
it's like what it what
like just imagine that guy going home
after that just like in his car shirt
off and like because he took
he took his blazer off because he went
to go home and he was like i [ __ ]
sweated when i did that rap and then
he's in the car and so he blasted the
[ __ ] air conditioning and then he's
like oh actually it's [ __ ] i
shouldn't have took my blazer off now
i'm actually cold and then he's [ __ ]
driving home and he can't get the air
right and then like this is the [ __ ]
he's thinking of now and and the fact
that he just [ __ ] embarrassed himself
in front of everybody
yeah there's a city council meeting
and then like just went home and just
you know he slept like a [ __ ] baby
that night that's what i love thinking
about
i love how this [ __ ] woman mother of
34 is left red-faced after drunkenly
ordering an uber xl to ukraine to help
out but thankfully the four thousand
seven hundred pounds payment bounced
because of insufficient funds in her
account
mother of two leone field is 34 from
greater greater manchester and a pal
we're talking about conflict in ukraine
on a night out while drinking few double
pink gins and shots of sambuca and they
wanted to [ __ ] go to help out imagine
her going
in her heels on the dress from that
night out just how drunk do you
this is see this is where this is what
you're [ __ ] uh this is what all your
[ __ ] black squares and pray for the
ukraine tweets are doing this is what
all your black squares on instagram do
they make mothers of 34 think that they
can actually take a [ __ ] uber xl to
ukraine and do what
what you gonna do
give suck jobs
what's helping the ukraine yeah you
might still get [ __ ] blasted in the
head but blast in my mouth first
oh sorry for all the bullets whizzing by
but you wanna suck job what's she gonna
do with her [ __ ] clack clack heels
and clack [ __ ] and mimosas hey what's up
ukraine did you guys wanted to be
did you guys wanted to be helped
oh my god it's so dusty what the [ __ ]
hey ukraine
hey ukraine you you what's your name
that is your name vladimir too it's like
two guys vladimir vladimir putin and
vladimir volinsky
hey
just like vladimir putin and vladimir
golinsky are you vladimir too like what
the [ __ ]
whoa
bullet oh my god everyone almost died
hey why is this so dusty is this inside
or outside you want a suck job
hey
vladimir my name is not vladimir fine
i'm gonna suck off any vladimir i meet
my name is vladimir
okay
[Music]
what kind of music can you put some
music on
we are not allowed to listen to music
also there are no speakers left
why parents on us
they are there has not been sonos
seen here yet we don't have we were
going to maybe have sonos and then all
that water broke out you had a suck job
yes
oh my god where can we do it though you
know it's still hard to get her you know
she drove over to do it but it's still
hard because [ __ ] chicks are always
like yeah and then they're like well
let's well do you have it you know
you're a suck job
yes absolutely 100
i don't know you seem like not sure
chicks are unreal dude
i don't know though is this insider
outside the the walls have been exploded
because we are at war are you going to
give me suck job or not oh god where's
the drinks
we haven't had drinks for a long time
we're in war
oh my god what is that birthmark i have
been shot
oh my god it hurts let's get you to help
can i just have my suck job please
can't connect with these sonos
[Laughter]
just tanks and [ __ ] oh my god it's so
loud what the [ __ ]
they just ran over my cousin
oh my god is that a [ __ ] humvee
i love that color it's like it's like
green but like brown on it
i love how colors like green but like
brown on that that's dirt [ __ ] are you
going to suck me off
can i get money for uber back
where do you live
len's in town dude i hate when people
say [ __ ] in london town i heard somebody
say london down the other day just like
[ __ ] call it london dude
like london town like you know how suck
[ __ ] [ __ ] that is
like london town dude like new york city
there's new york in the new york city
call it london city london town is so
[ __ ] dude
where are you from i'm from london town
oh london
yes
actually yes that is what that is but
mother of two where did mom go
huh where did mom go oh she's been out
late last night let me look at her find
my and find my [ __ ] i'm gonna find my
app
[Music]
[Laughter]
what the dad what the [ __ ]
oh the [ __ ] she's in the ukraine is she
abducted try to facetime her
oh my god hold on put your penis away
hey what's up
where are you honey are you inside or
outside i don't know i met this [ __ ]
guy's name's vladimir he won't leave me
alone
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you said you'd suck dick what did
he say
he won't leave me alone why are you in
the ukraine darling um because i'm
trying to help out
oh my god look at the [ __ ] color of
that car
are you going to suck me off who are you
with who are you with darling are you
going to suck someone off i keep hearing
someone saying sex coming off i'm
vlogging me
i wanted to suck him off but he doesn't
really seem like he wants to i i will
say again if 100
want you to suck me off and then he just
doesn't really seem like into it
[Laughter]
dude
you guys screaming
um
just uh that's so funny to think of
ukrainian soldiers just like this is
[ __ ] such [ __ ] it was hard enough
trying to stay alive and [ __ ] i watch
all my cousins die and now i have to
deal with this [ __ ] that promising blow
job that not giving it to me
i keep telling her i 100 want but she's
saying oh i'm not that interested i
don't know how to [ __ ] show her more
interest
i had to watch my cousin die and now i
can't get [ __ ] from good [ __ ] so
promise me [ __ ]
um
anyway
you see this tesla jump in the [ __ ]
i saw it on foo's gone wild which is
hilarious foo's gone wild on the
instagram
oh [ __ ]
oh
[ __ ] that is the worst idea dude
this you know how i get those worse idea
the silence from everyone around it that
didn't go oh
oh my god dude this car just [ __ ]
oh my god dude
this is crazy
you know what it's like
someone needs to put this to them
[Music]
where it's all of a sudden they're in
the outer space
[Music]
dude that is unreal that thing took off
like i had wings dude why the [ __ ] did
they do this
wow
we had a technical thing there we had to
[ __ ]
uh well technically it had a single
thing technically i had to take a pee
pee so now i'm back um
this dude this is the thing i wanted to
fi i
can't even forget about this this pastor
greg locke
dude pastor's got some egos huh
threatened to expose the six witches who
are members of this church here we go
we got first
and last names
of six witches there you go there that
everyone should be going like this okay
we gotta go we gotta go i mean dude
imagine
like the seriousness he's saying look
this is the next thing this is what you
hear after this that's what you got
first
and last names
are six witches grab my purse we've got
to go that are in our church and you
know what's strange three of you are in
this room right now
no they're not dude there are not three
of you witches of the six witches in the
room right now because there are not
witches in this room because there are
not witches
we all know that
let's continue
[ __ ] how we did it
when he [ __ ] did the microphone in
the thing dude unbelievable that's the
most dude that hop was so [ __ ] dude
have you i mean i can watch it
dude
wow man we got to see that again
unbelievable i'm going to see that we
got to see the whole lead up the most
[ __ ] hop of all time well hops are
always [ __ ] honestly for real but jesus
christ this [ __ ] [ __ ] and how he
tapped the [ __ ] podium oh my god dude
i live for [ __ ] like this dude
we got first feeling himself i love last
name i love it because he's going like
this you know what dude i know what i'm
saying is controversial and the
mainstream doesn't understand that
there's witches and they might be
sniffing out some insecurity on my end
so what i'm going to do is double down
on it be so confident and
and so he starts speaking with such
utmost confidence gets a little bit
carried away and taps the podium while
does a [ __ ] [ __ ] hop and that's when
the inner [ __ ] is exposed the inner
[ __ ] is always exposed if you're cincy
it's coming out if you're from
cincinnati you can go to any state you
want but you can't remove the scentsy
from yourself
and that's on god
oh six witches
come on we gotta watch it from the
beginning dude first
and last names
of six witches
that are in our church here we go and
you know what's strange three of you not
streaming in this room right now the
whole thing straight away
[Music]
[Laughter]
three of you in the room right now oh
you better look at my eyeballs we ain't
afraid of you you stinking witch you
devil worshiping satan this witch we
cast you out in the name of jesus christ
we break your spells we break your curse
we got your first name we got your last
name we even got an address for one of
you
wwe
this is unbelievable dude
unbelievable we even got your address
what up y'all
didn't know how to end it
unbelievable dude why is wearing a
[ __ ] hogwarts shirt dude unbelievable
why is he from hogwarts
is he from slytherin dude this is unbel
the guitar's in the back you know dude
this whole clip is [ __ ]
unreal dude
the [ __ ] that's the most bit [ __ ]
i've seen in 2022. and and i'm saying
hands down that's on god dude
let's see the rest of it i i watched the
beginning of it and i saved the rest of
the podcast because i want to get the
honest reaction
you stinking witch yeah hates his words
we're sent to this church to destroy us
you were sent to this church to lure us
in you were sent to this church to cast
spell this also also also dude
the three of the people that are the
witches
they don't even know they're the witches
everyone's just looking around like i
wonder who he means and it's one of them
is you
dude so
focused on getting these three witches
also where are the other three witches
get to get them all
don't be so [ __ ] like is it
lackadaisical or like a days ago yeah
some of you been sick because you
befriended that witch
two of you in my wife's latest bible
study and you know who you are and we
gonna ask you to get out
dude they [ __ ] he flirted with him
and she told his wife about it and now
he's [ __ ] doing it like this
oh dude two of them said about my last
bible study and then you got to get out
dude he flirted with him because he said
well boy don't he said don't those
because this is what he said to both of
them and it didn't work well don't those
hush puppies look nice in that shirt
it didn't work with one thing oh my god
oh my god and then the other one went oh
my god and then [ __ ] he's like well
you're witches and everybody
we got all six of their names
okay say them oh six of them
two of them had already been confirmed
for that thing everyone said it no hates
the two of them so much the way he
[ __ ] got
he goes like this
holy [ __ ] this guy's on fire
oh just one person yeah first and last
night this chick is new to our church
and don't know none of you
more is more disrespectful to call her a
chick like that then [ __ ] call her a
stinking witch
you got a choice
you can leave with your spells
all by yourself
or i'll show up next sunday
with a stage full of brooms
and i'll give you one and i'll fly your
tail up out of this place in the name of
jesus but we ain't playing your spell
casted witchcraft nonsense sage burning
games
everybody okay
the witches are like nope
and your little dog too you're out witch
wow dude that guy had the [ __ ]
greatest childhood of all time and just
thinks everything he says is so dope
dude it's so
bro the [ __ ]
first of all don't need a stage full of
brooms you know if there's only six of
them just bring that and only two showed
up bring two
unbelievable what do you say here at the
end though
games
everybody okay
knows you went too far
the witches are like
nope
stand up and you're a little dog too
you're out killing a witch killing it
unbelievable dude
this guy is just
who are the witches
can you tell us
who are the people that believe this
you're out
you're out who is this guy greg locke
uh dude if i were there i swear to you
i would stand up and be like yo i'm one
what if he was just like we don't want
you here
get your spells out of here and i people
in the arjuna and a [ __ ] light beam
just was coming out of his mouth dude
that then i would then i would believe
there were witches there
meeple orphan gin that's what a lot
and all of a sudden those [ __ ]
like the the [ __ ] uh on the eyes wide
shut with the [ __ ] black cloaks and
the [ __ ] dick noses come in memphis
just grabbing titties and [ __ ] memes
remember that [ __ ] i love that movie
dude
makes no sense love movies that make no
sense [ __ ] hate when movies try to
make sense dude it's so annoying when a
movie tries to be linear and makes sense
because it doesn't anyway so make
[ __ ] eyes wide shut and that's it
dude i said it and it's crystallized so
you know who did it
[Music]
guys
[ __ ] yeah dude
[Applause]
david lynch didn't do it then i [ __ ]
good morning you know many dozen hi the
weather in l.a today is sunny dude david
lynch is on his website and he does
[ __ ] weather reports dude we have the
weather reports for weather reports or
you can just open the window david lynch
makes no sense and that's my favorite
living director
dude the blue cube and maul and drive
what does it mean
i'm in dude
i love non-linear movies that make no
sense with [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] witches
behind dumpsters that come out and steal
your soul
well it's you know
i even like the bad ones dude
lost highway i like it
he likes the left side oh jesus christ
he likes lost highway what the [ __ ] dude
oh but who's in that bill pullman i
can't even build a person or cat oh
those two people should never be in a
movie together nothing could be more 90s
oh
pulling but
pictures are you gonna put them in the
movies
uh
[Laughter]
dude
[Music]
all right well i guess that's good huh
i guess we're at phoenix i'm coming
chrisleya.com irvine california
chrisley.com go get your don't push me
merch and show up to the shows with them
and also wear
the don't push me merch and the oops
merch and all of the merch the life rip
[ __ ] on at all the comedian shows that's
how you let him know this cult is this
is a [ __ ] this is the thing dude this
is the cult
and this is a movement dude
you're either with me or against me at
this point and if you're with me
it's us
it's us dude
we're a pimp
in the blimp
and you get with us and all your dogs
will be immortal
do you understand me
hey guys that's the end of the episode
for youtube but if you want to catch the
rest of the episode go on over to our
patreon patreon.comcrystalia
and for six bucks a month you can not
only watch the rest of this episode you
can watch the rest of every episode
that's ever been made since patreon and
you can also get the back episodes that
you've missed that are still on patreon
and what are there's like 12 now dude
six bucks
watch it up there's also review mode the
segment that we do there's behind the
scenes stuff footage and a discord that
we all chat on get involved patreon.com
crystallia thanks guys
[Music]
sound sound sound